the dance of dragons is the story of the
fight between rira Targaryen and her
half by the rean for control of the
Seven
Kingdoms a true telling by grandm monin
being a history of the war of targaryan
succession between the princess fera and
aegon second of his name that nearly
destroyed the
realm one night a servant found the Old
King had died in his sleep protocol
dictated that the bells would be rung
and a raven sent to Dragonstone to
summon the air princess rira for her
coronation but Allison had other plans
so Otto hiow the hand of the king and
father to Queen Allison demanded that
the succession be settled immediately
the Old King had forced the Lords of
Westeros to swear fty to princess rira
as his Heir but sir Christen Co rightly
pointed out that a son comes before a
daughter
both of them thought they belonged on
the Iron Throne when people started
declaring for one of them or the other
their fight divided the kingdoms in Two
Brothers fought Brothers dragons fought
Dragons by the time it was over
thousands were
dead and it was a disaster for the
targarian as well they never truly
[Music]
recovered
during the Great Targaryen civil war
known as the dance of the Dragons a king
and queen each vied for the throne
dividing their house and its dragons
against each other eventually the queen
was fed to her rival's Dragon while her
son watched and the Victorious King soon
died of his own wounds by the war's end
King's Landing was smashed cities raised
and sacked never to be rebuilt and
Dragons had faded from this
world
for free you can now listen to the
entire audiobook Fire and Blood On which
house of the Dragon is based and which
covers the entire targarian history
including current and future events of
House of the Dragon for free with a
notable trial using our Link in the
description